- Like you need to figure
out what works for you.
We're very empathy, so for all
this speed and whatever we have
a lot of good things and
empathy would be one of them.
So, you know, I think I don't
get burned out even though
I go so hard every day
always because
I just know,
first of all it doesn't happen
that often because I love it so
much but I know that if it's not
clicking right that I have my
levels to escape.
Whether that's, I think this
going to sound very weird,
the Jet games help me a lot.
I'm not kidding like
I release of stress.
You know, if I have
to take, you know,
if on the weekend if I have
to completely shut down.
Also perspective,
I think I'm really
blessed and it's hard for
me to complain about work.
In a world where every day
'cause were big company now,
I have emails of like my
mom has open-heart surgery,
my cousin died,
we had a miscarriage.
In a world where every single
day now because of how many
people I'm connected to and how
many people work for me that
I hear something
that's real every day,
it's just hard for me to say
like I fucked up this project or
I lost this account or I got
employees that are stressed.
These are real things but
they're still business and they're
champagne problems compared to,
you know, I just kind of every
day like if everybody's healthy
like I'm not joking like my
perspective is on point.
You know?
And that's what I
would say to you use me,
use Claude, use Erin, use
whatever is right for you to as
much as it'd might be like fuck
I don't want to be here to
11 o'clock at night or this is
too much pressure or
I hate these two people are
fucking always conflicted and so
whatever it may be
find a way to communicate
it out to whomever,
internally, dumping everything
on your partner or mom or dad
that's like always tough.
That's what most people do,
that's why family dynamics are
interesting but please rest
assured that that's super
interesting for me that empower
everybody here to have an outlet
in whatever way I can be
including that's why we have
unlimited vacation time.
You know like getting ahead
of that and I think people put
their own pressure on it.
We have such a great company and
people have so much pride like
I can't just do that.
We have these projects,
it's understanding you can and
understanding that the
masses can fulfill that.
It's just communicating and
that's what I do I communicate
with myself first and then I
communicate with whomever else.
For me, it's a little bit lonely
because all on me kind of thing.
You know, if everybody
takes a day off that's on me,
you know?
But I think that's how to be
honest with you perspective,
an understanding and through
that perspective understanding
that it's all gonna be alright.
- [Woman] Okay.
- You know?
So what I want to do is five
minutes is like pound that home
for you if you communicate,
there's nothing scary here.
If people are good at what
they do and they have the right
intent they're gonna win.